okay there's something really
interesting going on the right has been
totally bamboozled by the quite frankly
as I've said before very well done
exoneration campaign that has been waged
by Donald Trump around the Moller report
but if there's any good news to be
gleaned from the reaction to the Moller
report it's that the country overall
doesn't actually seem to have fallen for
it and Donald Trump's approval rating
has dropped to the lowest of 2019 so far
since the Moller report was published
and I've already told you how well
executed Donald Trump's plan was from
the get-go for appealing to his base he
put in William Baris Attorney General
William Bar is an expert in covering up
presidential wrongdoing Barr wrote this
four-page public relations document
which was then used to justify a
nationwide exoneration tour and
right-wing media tour for Donald Trump
and his advisers then the Moller report
actually comes out but before it's
released
William Bar gives this propaganda press
conference on Thursday morning
effectively framing Trump as a victim of
a totally unfair investigation that
William Barr implied didn't make any
sense to even do from the beginning
that's what they did but as I already
told you when you look at the content of
the Moller report it's extraordinarily
damning to Donald Trump and to everybody
around him it states that there's quote
substantial evidence that Donald Trump
obstructed justice it confirms almost
every major investigative story that was
reported over the last two years related
to the probe and the campaign as we
already talked about at the top of the
show today and it seems that while
Donald Trump's exoneration propaganda
campaign worked really well with his
base it doesn't appear to be working
well with the American public in total
because there's a new reuters/ipsos poll
which has Donald Trump's approval down
to 37% this is the lowest of 2019
68% of Americans
they are more likely than before the
report came out to believe that Donald
Trump or his cronies committed crimes
half the country believes that Donald
Trump tried to stop the Muller
investigation which is disturbing that
it's only 50% it should be a hundred
percent because he actually admitted to
this on national television so now we
have to ask the question of whether this
is good news or bad news and
unfortunately even though it's good that
the Muller report propaganda campaign
has not convinced all of the country it
seems to really have most worked mostly
on Donald Trump's base there's a lot of
bad news here and the bad news is that
while it's good that Trump's approval
rating is down as a result of the Moller
report because it should be because the
Moller report contains endless damning
evidence about what Donald Trump and the
people around him did his approval
rating should have already been down to
just his hardcore base months ago that
it shouldn't actually move with news
like the Muller report what what I mean
is that there's some portion of the
population I've guessed before that it's
in the range of 28 to 30 maybe 32
percent which is what I call the shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue crowd meaning
that no matter what Donald Trump does
they're going to support him even if he
shoots someone on Fifth Avenue as Donald
Trump I guess you could say joked about
a couple of times if you're not in that
twenty eight to thirty percent base you
should have been so disgusted with
Donald Trump already that it shouldn't
really move the approval rating for
Donald Trump to be so exposed as
involved in so much wrongdoing by the
Mullah report if you think back to
George W Bush I believe that his low
approval rating ever was maybe twenty
nine percent maybe twenty eight percent
something like that and that seems to
sort of be what I would call the
partisan floor for a president given how
polarized American politics is twenty
eight twenty nine thirty seems to be
kind of like rock-bottom no matter what
a president does they're not going to go
below that tax cuts for the rich should
have already dropped anyone who is
reacting to the facts should have
already dropped Trump's approval rating
to that rock-bottom broken promise after
broken promise should have already
gotten us down to just that hardcore
base caging kids should have gotten us
down to just that hardcore base trying
to take health care away from tens of
millions of people
inciting white supremacy anti
anti-semitism and xenophobia the fact
that there's anybody left supporting
Trump who's actually influenced by the
news is concerning to me and the the the
sort of the good news it's always good
when the country reacts correctly by
saying oh I just learned about X I no
longer support the president that's good
but the bad news is that Trump still has
more than just his base supporting him
there are people beyond just the Fifth
Avenue shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
crowd who are saying I'm looking at what
Trump is doing and I'm actually deciding
that I like it and that's
extraordinarily concerning and that gets
us to 20/20 I've said this before it
bears repeating when half the country
doesn't vote with 37% approval and 50%
turnout you can win okay with 18 19
percent of the total voting public
voting for Trump with the electoral
college system that we have Trump can
win reelection easily assuming that he
campaigns in the right places and gets
the votes in in in the right places
which means once again that if we were
waiting for the molar probe to take down
Trump that was always a bad idea as I've
been telling you for years at this point
but it's really time to realize that
2020 is going to be about turnout that
being said momentum for impeachment of
the president is growing and I'm going
to talk about that after today's
interview I still don't think it's a
good political strategy I still don't
think it's likely to actually do
anything before the November 20 2011
vigor ating what I would call more
serious conversation
about impeachment and we will talk about
those later in the show
after our interview make sure you're
following the show on instagram at david
pakman show make sure you follow me on
Instagram as well at David Pakman I
actually posted a picture from a
Passover Seder I attended over the
weekend and it angered a lot of people
check out the comments follow me on
instagram at david pakman quick break
plenty more coming up right after this
today's sponsor is Skillshare and i'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than 10 bucks a month
get better at whatever it is that you're
passionate about or discover something
brand new that you didn't even know that
you would love and join skill shares
other 7 million users by clicking the
link underneath this video
[Music]